the key thing to remember if an
international student thinking of
applying to Oxford is the criteria isn't
different because you're an
international student the two main ones
are do you have the academic merits to
study here and do you have the potential
to go on and do great things within and
outside the university so are you going
to have the potential to succeed there
are two questions that were asking when
we're looking at every single
application irrespective of whether it's
a home application or an international
application you don't have to study a
levels and if you've not done GCC's
please don't worry you will probably
have to do an English language module if
you if you if English is in your first
language but irrespective we have
criteria for looking at different types
of qualification so I really recommend
that you go on to the international
students area of the Oxford website
because in many ways we're hitting a
moving target things change all the time
particularly in terms of funding and
fees so really how I recommend you check
out the tools on the oxygen University
website that's the fees and funding tool
and the tour relating to international
qualifications and how they relate and
compare it to UK qualifications thank
you so much to Dan for agreeing to be
interviewed if you'd like to check out
more videos about Oxford and Cambridge
admissions then check out the playlist
that's on the screen now and linked in
the description below also take a look
at the social media links in the
description for Sint Peter's College
which is mile college there are links to
Facebook Twitter snapchat and Instagram
where you can see a snapshot of student
life at an Oxford College